[Music]
hey guys it's dawn here a quick update
before we start this video I've decided
to postpone my current project I'm
working on for a little bit longer while
working on the video I realized that
this is simply not a video that's worth
rushing out in just a week the video
will be about the day of the great
calamity in full detail so this includes
every significant battle the path of
destruction the Guardians took the key
players evacuation routes of the works
this project just got bigger and bigger
and as of right now it's looking to be
around 30 minutes long here's a little
snippet of one of the animations and
well this is just a very small part of
it as you can see from this screenshot
right here combine this with pretty long
render times for instance this 30 second
clip already took more than an hour to
render and I'm estimating that the total
amount of map animations alone will be
about 6 to 8 minutes so that's close to
a full day I'll be losing on rendering
the map out alone
I want my main videos to be as good as
they can possibly be something to be
proud of and I just know I'm going to
regret if I cut corners and rush it out
I'm not sure yet when I'll be releasing
the video I'm aiming for later next week
but that also strongly depends on if
we'll be seeing a Nintendo Direct this
week if we get to see brand new breath
the wall 2 footage for instance I'm sure
you can understand I'm going to
prioritize focusing on the new stuff
first not to mention that I also edit
for Commonwealth realm which means that
the direct will mean next week is going
to be absolutely bonkers when it comes
to my work schedule but I still wanted
to give you something to watch for this
weekend so this video seems like a nice
little thing to hold you over speaking
of possible directs let's cut to the
chase and talk about the possibilities
for breath the wall - now I'm not doing
a full predictions video in regards to
other titles there's plenty of other
channels out there with actual gaming
journalists and who have much more
knowledge and connections to the
industry and I'm not interested in
becoming a Nintendo news channel so I
will focus primarily on Zelda here it's
important to say it upfront that as of
right now although the likelihood of a
Nintendo Direct early next week is
growing more and more as of yet nothing
has been confirmed by Nintendo directly
despite all the evidence this is still
based on predictions leaks and
discoveries that could solidify enough
direct but could also just as well turn
out to be coincidences in a nutshell in
case you missed it this whole July
direct thing started with a guy named
Kelly Oz who made a tweet hinting to an
intended direct on July 20th in most
cases this whole direct prediction thing
would have probably been brushed off as
just some baseless rumor
however Kelly Oz has a very promising
track record when it comes to making
predictions for instance he predicted
the mini direct earlier this year to the
exact day and previously also hinted
that Pokemon go three days before it was
announced just to name a few now Kelly
Oz has made it abundantly clear on his
Twitter that he does not work in the
gaming industry he is the webmaster for
a French Pokemon news website coca-cola
zfr however the fact that he has
successfully predicted things in the
past with stunning accuracy indicates
that at the very least he has some
connections at Nintendo most likely
Nintendo of France perhaps even Nintendo
of Europe and since then more and more
people with possible insider info have
chimed in claiming that yes this is
indeed happening most of us were
expecting or hoping for an announcement
this week but as of the time of making
this video this is yet to happen and
since according to the leaks it's
supposed to be happening tomorrow I
think it's safe to say that if this is
indeed all true this is most likely
going to be a shadow drop aka no prior
announcements just like they did with
the direct mini back in March
who knows maybe Nintendo even spread the
info about this direct on purpose as a
means to create hype for the event
rather than making the announcement
themselves despite getting no heads-up
from Nintendo this week Kelly Oz has not
retracted his claims not even after some
impatient trolls made a fake Twitter
account copying his and mocking his
predictions he's sticking to his guns on
this one so with that said will we see
breath of the wild - well this of course
depends on the kind of direct it will be
a full direct a mini a general theme
direct or a direct focused on a specific
franchise we of course all know that
this is Mario's 35th anniversary so we
can at least expect some Mario stuff to
pop up but there are several claims
floating around that despite this in
terms of the theme it will not just be
mario kelly us himself states that if
they do not announce anything prior it
will most likely be a mini if they do
announce something in advance
it could be a full direct now if you're
worried about this let's remember that a
direct mini doesn't mean it will be
insignificant for instance the mini from
March of this year was actually longer
than Nintendo's e3 presentation in 2017
besides less runtime does not equal less
important news as it stands right now
Nintendo has close to nothing to show
for when it comes to the remainder of
2020 now that Paper Mario the origami
King is out there's very little left in
the tank so even if this will be a mini
that still leaves a chance for some big
announcements sure they could wait until
later this year like say September but
by that point we only have three months
left
I highly doubt they will both announce
and release their holiday title or
titles this close to December I know
there are still some brave souls out
there who are still clinging on to hope
for a 2020 release for breath the well -
but let's face it if zelda really was
releasing this year we would have seen
more activity surrounding the game a
gameplay trailer at the Game Awards last
year or early this year lots of small
updates and PR etc even if the game is
further into development than Nintendo
has been willing to show we simply don't
know enough about this game
we have no title no gameplay no nothing
just a very short story trailer the
release of the sequel to the
best-selling Zelda game ever isn't going
to be a casual guess what it's coming
out in three months the same thing goes
for other triple-a IPs like Metroid 3d
Mario or Pikmin these games take years
to develop and are usually paired with
an elaborate marketing campaign leading
up to its release
if this direct will feature multiple
first party reveals most if not all of
them will probably not release this year
for reasons I've mentioned previously I
could see a 2d Metroid or several
remasters of other games making it this
year for sure and we might even see
Skyward Sword HD getting announced for
this holiday who knows it all depends on
what this direct is supposed to be if
it's a collection of things that were
meant to be shown during e3 before it
got canceled then yes I could definitely
see breath the wall - making an
appearance if it's just a little thing
to hold us over until the next real
direct then chances of seeing zelda
become a lot more slim mario will
probably be hogging a large portion of
this event there's also talk about
fzero announcement and of course hopes
and dreams for something Metroid or
Pikmin related as much as I am an
optimist I highly doubt we will see all
of these games revealed in just one
direct mini if it's a mini of course if
it's a full direct maybe but let's not
forget that out of all triple-a titles
Zelda is the only one we know is in
development right now the only game to
be officially announced sure Nintendo is
very much aware of the anticipation and
impatience surrounding this game so it
would make sense that if it's more than
just Mario in terms of big reveals Zelda
is a likely candidate so let's pretend
that this direct is happening tomorrow
and breadth the well - will be part of
it what will we see well first of all I
don't think we're gonna see a release
date yet a release year maybe but no
specific dates I think they made that
mistake too many times with breath the
wild speaking of which there is of
course the possibility that Nintendo
isn't ready to show detailed gameplay
yet in which case they might do
something similar to 2015 when Twilight
Princess HD was announced and only show
a very brief teaser say for instance if
Skyward Sword HD is revealed throwing a
little bone for the fans waiting for
breath - well - and saved a real deal
for later this year perhaps like the
Game Awards or something if we get more
than just a teaser but an actual proper
trailer it's quite certain that we will
see actual gameplay this time I think
Nintendo knows at this stage they can no
longer drop just another story trailer
people are gonna want to know what this
game is actually all about even for
breath the wild we already got to see
actual gameplay footage as early as six
months after the first review granted
still in a very primitive state but
gameplay nonetheless I do think that if
we get a proper trailer we will see a
name reveal which would be nice since
I'm quite tired of calling this game
breath of the wild - as much as I want
to see the game I also need to keep
myself in check and stay realistic the
chance of seeing anything related to the
game during tomorrow's hypothetical
direct is 50/50 at best in my opinion
like I said before it all depends on
what the goal of this direct is which as
of right now we have no clue about not
even the ones who predicted it like
kellyo seem to know when it comes to the
sequel opinions seem to vary greatly
some think it's highly on
likely we will see anything soon others
think it's almost certain at the end of
the day only time will tell so let's all
keep our eyes open tomorrow and keep
refreshing that Nintendo Twitter page
thank you all for watching I will keep
you guys and gals up-to-date when it
comes to my schedule for the upcoming
weeks very soon obviously if we get some
significant news tomorrow or maybe even
later this week I will start working on
a video related to it I won't be listing
any new patreon in this video since I
will save that for my real videos it
seems only fair I will see you all in
the next video and this is Don signing
off and have a good one wait is it
signing off or signing out I've been
saying signing off for a long time now
but I'm starting to have my doubts I've
heard other youtubers say signing out so
is signing off even correct English can
anybody let me know thanks